a lot of people throughout the were deaf
boy this season it's so annoying in an
interesting situation right now with
Christina and Danielle you know
Christina is very very invested in our
relationship but I'm very interested in
attracted to Danielle I don't know if I
necessarily qualify myself as an F boy
and of course it's everyone's freedom of
expression to call me whatever they want
to call me but at this point is just
getting overplayed and overused and I
wall I disagree with it I can see what
how my actions reflect it but every time
I see that comment on my Instagram I'm
like just a part of me dies inside I'm
just like figuring it out I thought that
like by being open about my feelings for
both of them with each other like it
would be reason enough for you know say
Christina didn't think something was
like permissible then should be like all
right like this is relativities to end
right now so it was kind of like my like
cop-out way or like my like scaredy-cat
way of being like all right like didn't
this is your reason to kind of end
things if you don't feel comfortable
with it but like looking back like I
never should have put her back in that
situation anyways you know I mean
there's no bad blood on my part I would
love to like have a relationship with
both of them in terms of like friendship
well there was a lot of fan push for you
to be the bachelor Mike Fleiss has
tweeted that you are not the bachelor
why are you not the best if you watch
two episodes of paradise you'll see it
very quickly while I'm not the best was
it ever a discussion
I I talked about it very informally with
a few people but there was never like a
formal offer extent or anything like
that
[Music]